[Música]
día 42 de la invasión rusa en ucrania
moscú se repliega hacia la región del
donbass advierte el gobierno mi tierra
las autoridades ucranianas hicieron un
llamado a la población a evacuar esta
región en la ciudad de mario por han
muerto más de 5000 civiles denunció su
alcalde mientras que la otan asegura que
la guerra podría durar años
recta final de la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en francia a
cuatro días de los comicios así cuesta
seguir mostrando una ventaja cada vez
más estrecha entre el presidente y
candidato en manuel macro y la
ultraderechista marine lepén apenas tres
puntos y medio de margen según ifo como
se explica el auge de la extrema derecha
en este momento de la campaña les
explicamos
al menos cinco muertos es el saldo que
dejan días de protestas en perú las
movilizaciones lideradas por los
transportistas han evolucionado en un
rechazo contra el presidente pedro
castillo a quien acusan de incumplir sus
promesas electorales el país se prepara
para una jornada de manifestaciones a
nivel nacional este jueves tenemos
análisis
momento de actualizar las noticias en
france 24 gracias por seguir con nuestra
señal mi nombre es juan pupiales día 42
de la invasión de rusia en ucrania y
eeuu asegura que el kremlin completó la
retirada de sus tropas de la región de
kiev la capital y de chernin hiv al
norte según el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski moscú está enfocando
sus esfuerzos en la región del donbass
al este del territorio y que pueden ver
en rojo en el mapa en su pantalla es en
esas zonas en donde hay presencia rusa
mientras tanto en la ciudad en la
asediada ciudad de mariupol más de 5000
civiles han muerto de acuerdo con su
alcalde y el comité internacional de la
cruz roja informó que logró evacuar a
1000 personas de esta urbe hacia asia
por ella la vice primera ministra
ucraniana irina bereziuk anunció que en
total este miércoles fueron evacuadas
cuatro mil 892 personas en corredores
humanitarios
y ante esa concentración de las fuerzas
rusas en el donbass las autoridades de
lugares con una ciudad clave en esta
región instaron a la población a
abandonar la zona pero algunos
habitantes ya han preparado para
defender sus hogares ya sus familias
antes de ser destruido por las tropas
locales este puente era la única vía de
acceso al pueblo de bogor disk en el
este de ucrania
desde que moscú anunció su intención de
centrarse en lo que llamó la liberación
del donbass los residentes de la
tradicional región minera viven con el
temor constante de un asalto
que en este momento todo el mundo está
tenso todo el mundo está esperando que
ocurra algo pero en realidad no saben lo
que están esperando está
a pocos kilómetros de la línea del
frente las tropas rusas se acercan a la
zona desde el norte se han establecido
bloqueos de carreteras alrededor de
estos pueblos como parte de los
esfuerzos para frenar el avance de los
tanques rusos las tropas ucranianas
dicen que están preparadas para un
ataque común y a crucis con la
federación fascista rusa llegó a nuestra
sagrada tierra ucraniana con una espada
así que todos morirán aquí por espadas y
sargentos en este pueblo este monasterio
cuyo techo resultó afectado por las
explosiones se encuentra entre los
edificios dañados por la guerra es vía
tories está a sólo 45 kilómetros al
norte de la estratégica ciudad de sliven
basque las fuerzas ucranianas están
desplegadas en la zona desde 2014
y en abril de 2014 esta zona fue
capturada por un grupo de fuerzas
especiales rusas
y por lo que podemos deducir quieren
honrar este aniversario ahora capturando
estudiantes gaming
ante el temor de que una ofensiva rusa
sea inminente miles de civiles intentan
huir hacia el oeste cada día
en alemania el canciller olaf scholz
aseguró que tomará más medidas
contundentes para acabar con la
dependencia de su país de los
hidrocarburos rusos son las
declaraciones que coinciden con el
anuncio del denominado plan de pascua
cuando la k no tiene los detalles un
objetivo claro acabar con la dependencia
de hidrocarburos rusos el canciller
alemán olaf scholz aseguró que alemania
reestructurará su abastecimiento de gas
petróleo y carbón para generar una
independencia en términos energéticos
carnets cosa que ahora construiremos
capacidades de almacenamiento en la
costa norte de alemania a gran velocidad
ampliaremos las redes que son necesarias
para esto pero organizaremos las
estructuras de importación de carbón
petróleo y gas para que ya no dependemos
de las importaciones rusas a largo plazo
haremos esto con una velocidad sin
precedentes santa que eso indica tú
alemania se ha visto en una encrucijada
desde que comenzó la guerra en ucrania
su alta necesidad de hidrocarburos rusos
fue una de las razones por las que para
muchos scholz demoró su decisión en
aplicar sanciones más contundentes antes
del estallido del conflicto alemán ya
dependía en 55% de las importaciones de
gas ruso el país también importaba un
tercio del petróleo y 45% del carbón que
consumía desde rusia para revertir este
panorama el gobierno alemán presentó una
serie de medidas recogidas en el que
denominó como paquete de pascua que
asegura es el más grande de las últimas
dos décadas
de modo que este paquete este llamado
paquete de pascua también puede leerse
como una respuesta cuáles son los
intereses de la política de seguridad
alemana a saber independizarse primero
de las importaciones rusas de energía
fósil y luego de las importaciones de
energía fósil en general
una oleada de medidas que llega después
de que el gobierno tomara control de la
filial alemana de la empresa de gas ruso
gazprom
otra de las decisiones más contundentes
desde la cancelación del gasoducto nord
sueldos que es cambiar gas desde rusia
directa
hablamos ahora de las elecciones
francesas que celebran este domingo la
primera vuelta de los comicios
presidenciales la extrema derecha llega
con fuerza a esta cita con las urnas con
dos representantes harén depende
agrupación nacional y eric se moja de
reconquista los candidatos han apelado a
propuestas populistas y se han
abanderado de temas como la inmigración
y la seguridad pero se han intentado
distanciar el uno del otro a través de
matices en sus campañas y acusaciones
cruzadas cuando la carne y rafael pérez
traen los detalles a pesar de las
fracturas la extrema derecha ha logrado
abrirse un espacio considerable en el
electorado francés la pugna es entre la
candidata de la agrupación nacional
marine le pen y el representante de
reconquista edic se me llega con un voto
dividido porque entre ambos se pueden
estar contrarrestando
lp por un lado sigue por delante en lo
que sería el voto obrero el voto de la
clase trabajadora mientras que ese muro
está haciendo más hincapié en lo que es
la clase acomodada y los electores de
ese género con el antiguo legalismo
dependen alrededor del 22 por ciento de
los votos mientras que se mojó un 85
entre los dos superan el 27 por ciento
de los votos que obtendría el actual
mandatario enmanuel macrón en primera
vuelta según la encuesta ipsos ofra
desencantados inconformes con el
gobierno de macrón patriotas y
antisistemas son algunos de los
electores que se decantan por la extrema
derecha pero su discurso también ha
calado en parte de la juventud
principalmente porque ha salido a entre
otras entre otras cosas utilizadas muy
bien las redes sociales cosa que a la
izquierda no se ha sabido adaptar a ello
y además de tener la juventud que tiene
ciertos problemas
y en la derecha o la extrema derecha en
este caso le ofrecen soluciones
simplistas las banderas compartidas
entre los dos candidatos son muchas la
anti migración el orden la seguridad la
protección de los valores tradicionales
entre otras pero aun así intentan
distanciarse de moore de 63 años se
vendía como la novedad con una campaña
marcada por apelar a la emotividad y
exacerbando el discurso de la extrema
derecha sobre todo en temas de migración
proponiendo un ministerio encargado de
devolver a miles de personas a su país
somos los únicos herederos de la derecha
que amamos a francia a la gente al
trabajo al orden ya la identidad
depp en una cara conocida ha intentado
suavizar su imagen haciendo una campaña
más cercana a la gente concentrándose en
problemáticas concretas
contra el bloque de las élites contra la
oligarquía que encarna emanuel ma con
ésta el pueblo y el pueblo es más
numeroso que la casta a pesar de que
para muchos el discurso del epen estaba
desgastado las encuestas indican que se
enfrentaría a su antiguo rival el manual
macrón en una segunda vuelta
bien pero al menos cinco personas han
muerto en medio de las protestas que se
viven desde hace días en el país estas
marchas que comenzaron como un rechazo
por parte de los transportistas a los
precios del combustible han evolucionado
en un movimiento de rechazo contra el
presidente pedro castillo que lleva ocho
meses en el cargo entre los fallecidos
figura un menor de 13 años para analizar
ese tema conectamos con paula tábara
pineda politólogo y profesora en la
universidad pontificia en la pontificia
universidad católica del perú quien nos
atiende desde lima la capital gracias
profesora por estar con nosotros para
este jueves está convocada una gran
marcha nacional contra el presidente y
uno de sus asesores en reconocí que
ministros que han puesto su cargo a
disposición del mandatario es este el
momento más crítico de pedro castillo
desde que llegó al poder
buenas noches señor golpear es un gusto
si efectivamente este debe ser el
momento más crítico para el presidente
castillo por un lado porque son las
movilizaciones más grandes a las que se
está enfrentando hasta ahora había
habido movilizaciones incluso desde los
primeros días de su gestión pidiendo su
salida pero mucho más ideologizada de
determinados sectores de la derecha que
son los movimientos más grandes y además
esto tiene que tener en consideración
que varias de las regiones están
movilizadas ya estamos hablando de 15
por lo menos de las 25 regiones del país
son regiones en las que el presidente
castillo tuvo alto nivel de votación de
hecho la región de la que es originaria
para el partido político por el que
gobierna es una de las regiones donde se
ha puesto el foco del conflicto y donde
hay al menos tres de los fallecidos
nosotros estamos hablando de la pérdida
de legitimidad en un proyecto de un
presidente que se hizo llamar desde el
inicio el presidente del pueblo y del
gobierno del pueblo y que parece haber
perdido a ese pueblo del todo
a ver ustedes precisamente de una carga
ideológica en estas protestas se puede
decir de que hay una excusa para
intentar sacar a castelló del cargo
en un conjunto de los actores políticos
quizás quienes están más cercanos al
parlamento hay una búsqueda de razones
de excusas respectivamente que vienen
desde el inicio el presidente castillo
ya ha enfrentado en estos ocho meses dos
intentos de vacancia presidencial
dirigidos por esos partidos políticos
pero esos partidos políticos están
siendo rechazados también por quienes se
manifiestan parte de estas
movilizaciones y parte de lo que las
encuestas nos muestran que quiere la
ciudadanía no es sólo el cambio en torno
a las políticas que está ejerciendo el
presidente castillo e incluso la salida
de presidente castillo sino que se habla
de que se vayan todos
es decir que vayamos a unas nuevas
elecciones tanto presidenciales como
regionales es por allí donde está el
rechazo si bien se dirige al ser
presidente castillo porque había una
promesa de cambio y luego de ocho meses
la ciudadanía siente que no se han
cumplido con esos cambios prometidos
también hay un rechazo general a los
partidos políticos y el quehacer del
parlamento
porque y que está siendo uno de los
epicentros de esas marchas y también de
los enfrentamientos tiene eso que ver
con lo que usted nos comentaba antes de
que esas protestas ocurren en regiones
que votaron por pero castillo y que
ahora se sienten traicionadas
en el caso de la lista tiene que ver con
que efectivamente hay una importante
número de transportistas y que es una de
las zonas agrarias más importantes y por
tanto el costo del transporte pero el
costo también ellos llevan ya varios
años reclamando cambios en torno a las
normativas agrarias hace dos años
tuvimos una protesta en la zona que dejó
cerca de 4 fallecidos también es una
zona donde hay o donde se estarían
movilizando intereses también
partidarios de la oposición al
presidente castillo y si además una
región donde habiendo una gran
expectativa en determinado momento de
este gobierno pudiese por ejemplo hacer
esos ajustes pues ajustes en las
normativas agrarias no se han dado esto
sumado a huancayo y algunas gestiones
del país estarían siendo pues los puntos
en los que el presidente castillo
tendría que esperar su atención en los
próximos días
profesora muchísimas gracias vamos a
cambiar de tema vamos a grecia en donde
este miércoles se registró la primera
gran huelga nacional del año miles de
personas salieron a las calles de atenas
la capital para protestar contra los
altos niveles de inflación y los bajos
salarios convocados por los dos
sindicatos más grandes del país los
manifestantes se reunieron frente al
parlamento y marcharon para reclamar
aumentos salariales en medio de una
subida de precios a nivel general que se
agudizó tras la guerra en ucrania la
tasa de inflación anual de grecia saltó
al 7,2 por ciento en febrero desde el
6,2 por ciento de enero alcanzando el
nivel más alto desde
en noticias del continente africano
miles de personas marcharon en varias
ciudades de ciudad en rechazo al golpe
militar de octubre y la jornada termino
cobrándose la vida de al menos una
persona desde jartúm la capital hasta la
región occidental de darfur se vivieron
estas marchas en las que se pudo ver a
la policía reprimir a la multitud en
medio del mes sagrado del ramadán este
miércoles precisamente se cumplen tres
años desde la caída del ex presidente
omar al-bashir desde el 25 de octubre el
balance es de 94 fallecidos
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
pero que desde nuestra pantalla y
visiten también nuestro sitio web para
las 24 punto com
[Música]